this presentation is delivered by the
Stanford center for professional
development
hello everyone welcome to the Stanford
seminar in people computers InDesign
next week we have Joe fish Kay from
Yahoo who's going to be talking about
his recent work on families using
computers and tablets and this week we
have NEMA Mora veggie I've known NEMA
for six or seven years now NEMA was a
PhD student in computer science and
learning design and technology program
he defended his dissertation last year
and I got first to really know NEMA when
he was a student in my graduate class
and also a TA for the intro if CI course
and after that experience I wrote him a
recommendation letter for an internship
at Microsoft Research and I got a phone
call about that letter from from another
Stanford alum Mary Morris and she says
your letter says that NEMA is one of the
most autotelic people that you've ever
met what on earth does that mean and I
just said well hire him and you'll find
out and for those who are still
wondering I think the talk will
hopefully answer that question and to
tell you a little bit more about Eamon
he before coming to Stanford as a PhD
student helped run interaction design
for Microsoft Research in Asia and was
doing some very interesting ICT work
over there after getting his master's in
human-computer interaction and Carnegie
Mellon and he's done just some extremely
creative boundary crossing research and
you're about to hear from a lot of that
today I am floored thank you Scott I
appreciate that so first off Wendy jus
just had her second child I believe and
so she's not here today but I think you
know it's worth a moment of our time to
just recognize that you know that that's
really what we're all here for in the
end this whole science thing this whole
everything she's had a baby the human
species continues and yeah thank you
so I wish them I know we all wish them
the best so I got this call from Scott
or its email from Scotts and you know
hey this is happening do you want to
speak and I could take this talk in two
different directions right one could be
very okay how does what is the most kind
of traditional way that I could give
this talk or I could try to be you know
a little inspirational and experimental
and I chose that so I'm gonna try to
tell you speak pretty candidly about
what we're doing what we've been doing
and I would love to get your feedback
along the way or at the end of the of
the talk so just very quickly I feel
like every HCI talk should include this
and if your research let's just totally
can you can't figure out the Patras
spend some time and figure out how your
research might be deriving or inspired
by some of the work that's come before
us so left you have as we may think from
been of our Bush and I included the not
just a picture of Engelbart but this
particular picture of Engelbart because
I love it and it's just so it's just
looking at it as inspirational because
of his focus because of look how
important every word he says
look how important it is not only to him
but to the receiver of the information
you know and so I asked myself is what
I'm saying can I say it like this am I
saying it like this is it important
enough to me is it important enough to
the receiver to receive this information
and I also love it says five two three
in the back it's like that not the most
fancy formula by I don't know what it
actually means but I thought it was cool
and you know this this whole genre of
innovation that was occurring at the
time was really in the name loosely I
would generalize it as collective
intelligence which is a really you know
intriguing phrase but one of the things
that we all may be present
- is that sometimes there's such a push
for collective intelligence that we have
to be careful that it doesn't come at
the cost of individual intelligence or
individual clarity or individual
awareness of what where the collective
is actually going right so there's if we
if we sacrifice that there may be this
tendency to push towards collective
intelligence in such a way that we treat
the individuals like you know
insignificant automata or something
right just just kind of atoms right but
I think that if we can do both then
there's a really unprecedented
opportunity to achieve Engelbart's
vision so that means yes collective
intelligence is going to is is important
and it continues to be but are we taking
care of the individual along the way are
our tools empowering the most clear and
intelligent state of mind in the
individual as well and that's a big
question also another thing you should
include an HDI talk I've noticed there's
a quote inform Einstein I like this
quote and there's a lot of like quotes
from Einstein that are kind of supposed
quotes but you look like you're like
this if you really say that so I did a
little bit of research and this one he
actually did say so you can rest assured
that he said this and certainly we
should take care not to make the
intellect our god it has of course
powerful muscles but no personality it
cannot lead it can only serve and it is
not fastidious in its choice of a leader
it's like wow what are the implications
of that on our own research and our own
work and our own entrepreneurial work
perhaps so now I bring back this art
piece that I showed earlier when you
guys were walking in and you know I
would love to have a conversation about
how each of you relate to this or what
you take from it
I'll share with you my interpretation I
mean it's always hard to give a really
explicit interpretation of a piece of
art but you know it kind of it kind of
represents this idea I'm talking about
where you have individuals that are kind
of abstracted in you know individual
workers and contributors to global
society and economy but as we work
together we sometimes look and see
there's a whole other thing that's
missing there's a whole phenomena that's
occurring which is and I think you may
be experiencing this in your own life
your own sanity or what what what am i
what is the point it's going so fast
where do I go
status is extremely important you know
and it becomes more and more important
that haves the have-nots you know
there's just there's different ways you
can approach this idea but but there's
there's that there's what I'm kind of
speaking to is like let's not be afraid
to go there
let's not be afraid let's let's take our
creative creativity and our tools in our
research and think about the human
experience as well they the meaningful
human experience in life and how that
can complement collective intelligence
but also be important in its own right
and specifically I'll talk about what's
referred to as better sameness right are
we creating collective intelligence
tools that continue to kind of push us
in a certain direction or are we
rethinking how our tools should be
designed to ensure the most highly
productive and optimized individual work
and the collective work as well so I I
bring the discussion to this place that
we do a lot of our most creative
thinking and insightful thinking the
shower where is the collective
intelligence in there you know a lot of
great insights come from this magical
place that we often think is like you
know and as human as well from you like
Oh what is the
about the shower is it the water is it
the temperature is it that they did it
and it's like hey it's not the shower
it's you so why are you saying that it's
only when you're in the shower or in the
bathroom or in the forest why are you
putting that those constraints on
yourself
what are your win are your moments of
insight and clarity and creativity and
why why can't you you know be in control
of that so that you know it's not like
kind of work really hard and then play
hard or like work really hard and then
have a flash and stuff but rather our
work is sustainably directed towards a
very clear and a clear intention that we
really can get behind yeah exactly
that's a really good way to put it so so
you might think about the shower what's
happening in the shower when you shower
and you're you know an often way to
describe it is like I I'm just relaxed
or I'm not working or I'm just feeling
the water on my skin and I'm like wow I
have limbs you know oh I have this bump
on my knee I didn't know that where did
that come from or something right it's
like this whole other part of life that
we often don't engage with so really the
simplest way that I could phrase it was
it's like you're not stressed
in that moment I mean sometimes during
the shower and you're stressed you know
and you're not having a lot of insights
then probably you know I don't know but
but it's it's kind of I said you know
what it's something about stress okay so
you know you start looking at what
people are saying about stress learning
attention insight and there's a lot of
work in this area
Richard Davison does affective
neuroscience at Universal Wisconsin he's
like a real leader in studying
mindfulness and attention and you know
he his great quote attention is the
key to learning and meditate and
meditation helps you voluntarily
regulate it and that is one way of
regulating it but it's not the only way
right you can see the you know one
breath at a time is in the title of this
piece when I talk so the talk is called
augmented self-regulation okay so the
previous quote was about regulating your
attention right regulating where your
attention is going so you can ensure
optimal learning optimal productivity
even optimal communication relationships
just being present not being stressed
and distracted so what I the way I
phrase my expression of how technology
what the role of Technology is here is
this phrase Augmented self-regulation so
it's really empowering the individual
self regulation but augmented by our
tools and technologies so in the end our
innate ability to self-regulate
to ensure optimal all those things I
said productivity work all these things
can be augmented by our tools it can be
no it's often not it's often our tech
our systems and tools are just they're
kind of like to be used to be used and
they they're we don't acknowledge the
effect that they might have on our on
our ability to self-regulate so what's
happening now in cellphones it's like
wow you can chat with anybody at any
time and that's great but what is the
role they're having on our ability to
self-regulate I know that's explain that
very clearly but let me get into it a
bit well showers could be designed to to
play a role you know or I mean
intentionally designed yeah and I mean I
mean there are characteristics of the
shower that lend themselves to an
experience that is not stressful right
it's loud you know you can't use your
phone it's solitary I mean you know so
something like that
so I saw this this Web is webpage the
other day imaging study reveals
differences in brain function for
children with math anxiety I think it's
great research that they're doing
they're basically finding that fear is
the neural correlate for what we call
math anxiety but what I was what I was
focusing on was this idea of with math
anxiety it's like a thing like a with an
arm it's like a very real thing like you
have math anxiety you have this anxiety
and you know that strikes me as kind of
like it's a you know it's a label of
course but it also feels very real
rather than something that you may be
experiencing right and so
self-regulation is perhaps a way a child
or any of us can learn to work with such
a thing rather than saying oh no I have
this thing and I just it's just there
another way to look at it is this is the
cover of Scientific American mind last
year although we received formal
training and writing and math learning
how to manage stress is left entirely to
chance and I put this in here chronic
mild stress because often we think of
stress as like oh I have this big thing
due tomorrow and I'm totally stressed
out and that's like a very acute
stressor but I believe that there's this
more invisible stress this chronic mild
stress that's just pervading our day so
much that we don't even know it's there
we just think that that's how it is
until we maybe go camping or something
or we have a really intimate you know
experience with our family or friends
and we're like wow like that says this
is different you know this is not how I
always feel so right so the tools to
manage the stress are not we can't
really assume them this is the father of
modern research on stress hans selye a
canadian and he's got this great quote
so he differentiated between you stress
and distress like good stress and bad
stress anyway it's it's fascinating but
the quote really tells a great story
every stress leaves an indelible scar
and the org
and pays for its survival after a
stressful situation by becoming a little
older so that and I added the word
perceived stressful situation because
you know this may be force you to look
and put your head up that's an objective
stressor but me speaking here in front
of your crowd I could easily make this a
very stressful situation very easily and
I'm almost there no but but what the
point of the quote the reason I like it
is that it's it it's really describing
the mind-body connection in a very
simple way your your body responds to
stress by becoming a little older it's
like okay I dealt with that but there
was a little cost to my body right
oh I dealt with all those crazy emails
but I had to give up a little bit of my
youth you know physically physically and
and and I mean that literally be a knot
and I'll explain why so anybody know who
this is but this is Robert Sapolsky on
campus who's been a real just amazing
researcher in stress and so he's done a
whole bunch of work about how stress is
bad for your brain and your body and and
also how it occurs with social
hierarchies and things like that but
basically you're just going to trust me
that's what that's all about because I'm
not going to keep keep going on and on
about that but there's a lot of research
around stress has you know if you think
that you are performing best if you're
working hardest you may want to just
check and see well what is my best going
to be if I'm not just working
consistently maybe or directing the
attention to the most important tasks
these might be different from working
hardest kind of thing so just kind of
have clarity for yourself about how
you're working so I spoke earlier about
aging right so this is Elizabeth
Blackburn I used to
winning the Nobel in 2009 for her work
on telomeres which are the tips of your
chromosomes which is like if your
chromosome is a shoelace this is the tip
of your shoelace basically as you age
these tip shrinks and you have this
enzyme in your body called telomerase
which protects the the tip from
shrinking too fast but stress inhibits
the release of that enzyme so what's
really happening is that when you're
stressed your body can't maintain itself
it can't self regulate itself it it
sacrifices that ability and you're
literally aging and it's it's at a
cellular level this is how disease
happens and breakdown happens and so
that's that's kind of the the biological
proof of the aging but also in the
industry you know you have this pundit
Linda's stone talking about email apnea
or screen apnea you know and and I mean
you know she's not doing empirical
studies that are published but there's a
lot of people that are kind of saying
yeah I experienced that on Twitter and
she's got you know thousands of people
are like yeah yeah I totally ASA the
idea is that you know there's sleep
apnea but there's also email apnea right
or anytime you're in front of a screen
where is your breathing at that's what
she's kind of talking about so in effect
we know a lot about the why and the how
of stress we've become quite expert at
that but what's missing is and I think
this is this is what our work is about a
sustainable intervention and that could
be an intervention it could be an
intervention in the way that our systems
are designed to to mitigate those
problems and that's that's where that's
where our attention is today yeah
speaking more about technology but
absolute mean our social connections and
relationships fall into that category as
well so if you have this two dimensional
space
of your emotions fear being scared is
going to be up here being bored down
here relaxed might be here and being
really excited will be up here and so
often we we bounce around between these
like these quadrants without a lot of
attention to neutral our neutral space
right so that we and if and if we're if
we're in this neutral space our body is
doing all of the things that it needs to
do these self regulative processes
healing happens here right reproductive
things happen here and give us the
energy to win it when when there's a
need to be excited we can be excited
when there's a need to be scared we can
be scared and so on right so I call this
space calm you could call it whatever
you want another way to look at it is
restful alertness so this is not about
being relaxed of which is important too
but this is a sustainable state that you
can encounter on you do encounter
throughout your day you know if you find
yourself frequently in excited or
stimulated you might call it that's how
I know I often I'm in that space because
I'm responding to a lot of things well
just having having the word calm and
understanding what it might mean for you
could be helpful so here we are at
Stanford right the place where we create
a lot of the technologies that stimulate
people and allow them to do a lot of
things do new things and I thought that
I think it's really appropriate that we
do that but we're also very interested
in quality of life here right we're very
interested mean there's the whole duck
syndrome right we're very interested in
like being in nature eating good food
having great relationships so we're a
leader in both of these things and so
giving a name to this calming technology
lab a place where people can come to
think about these problems and use the
best skills of design
the research that they know from
whatever discipline they come don't come
from and studying and designing new ways
that can create the the environment for
productivity and communication that
we're used to with technology but also
acknowledging human nature acknowledging
what is best for humans which is going
to be an inclusion of that calm state
within in a day so transition now I'm
going to move to the next part of the
talk I put this in here for me but then
I was like you know like why not all of
us take a deep breath right so one thing
I notice when I do that is Wow
where was my breathing before that I
have to tell myself to take a deep
breath so that means that before that it
was not deep right where was it it was
shallow I don't know where yours was
probably maybe I don't know but you can
see that the breath which is a focus of
the one we'll be talking about today can
play a key role in this so this was the
first academic endeavor I made into this
idea a few years ago and you know if you
if you know about HCI there's this term
of the calm technology which is really
appropriate for the ubiquitous computing
field which is a from Mark Weiser blue
at Xerox PARC
and the idea is that the technologies
will be adapting to human beings as far
as when they should be bringing our us
attention and when they should be fading
back out it's not going to be like hey
hey hey this is happening this is
happening but when to fade out when to
stay in so it's calm technology and I
think that's great
the way I phrased calming technology was
that it's explicitly designed to induce
states of calm like it may be very
active in its interaction with you and
that's okay but the goal is to induce
that state of calm so I did this poster
and and then I
started teaching a class this is
decompress designing calm yet you may
know I don't know I really don't know
it's a good question
so this is the homepage for the
designing comm class I'll be teaching
this winter and I wanted to show you now
you might say what is what is the
calming technology look like I mean it
could look like a billion different
things I don't know but I wanted to give
some examples from student projects that
were created in the class so here is a
look forward so this was an idea where
the student said you know Facebook is
often about my past events and things
that I did but what was missing was
every time I think about the future I'm
stressed about my deadlines I want to
look forward positively to things so I
wanted to kind of tag people in the
future like I'm looking forward to
having lunch with with my girlfriend
tomorrow you know and that be and then
it would tag her and so on so it's just
an example this was a project where
after you step out of a lecture this
student would have a service that would
send a text message right after a
lecture so instead of feeling like oh my
god I have to remember all that
information it was like hey tell us what
tell us in five words an insight from
the class and so you might do that and
then a couple hours later you'd get a
text with five other people's insights
in the class or summaries of the class
and then you vote on your best your
favorite one at the end of the day you'd
see which one was the winner and the
idea there was that as soon as you step
out of the class instead of like having
this jumble of information in your head
and anxiety and fear you would say ah I
did some work I consolidated my
knowledge about this class I summarized
it for myself and for others it's gone
and then I see other people's
perspectives on it without actually
studying I can see oh well that was
there too oh and it's all bringing back
the class in a very kind of
low-bandwidth way and I vote and see the
best one it has a little bit of fun and
engagement in there as well so that was
the idea
because of class now I've got this yeah
so um so I think he did that because he
wanted people he wanted to motivate
people to account with something that
was going to you know resonate with more
people and be compelling to other people
it was more of I mean so this is a great
example of thinking about product design
and user experience design as well as
the calming aspect so creating something
that people going to be excited to use
and you know I could totally see it
going the other way or having that
connection between competition and
stress right yeah yeah it's just I mean
so that's a whole separate discussion I
won't go into but you know often what I
get from people what feedback I get is
that like yeah you know at some level if
you're interacting with anything there's
gonna be an element of stress right I
mean you're interacting with something
you're being demanded to respond and so
on and it's it's going to be up to the
designers to to really be artful in a
sense and also evaluate the effects of
different levers that they're
manipulating right so turning off the
competition seeing what happens for
which people your goal is call me what
you want like it your goal lecture calm
that's a subtly but importantly
different goal then should be lecture
having learned something from it and it
may be the case that the competition
helps force you to still with you got
out of it so you learn something even if
it induced a bit stressed yeah and it
may be that the the competition that you
felt before using such a service oh my
god there's always other students in the
class which one is the best and so on
that may be so high that it may be
precluding the learning whereas this
competition might be just the mean you
know there's different ways to approach
it
this is an example of a project it's
called with calling it Melo but this is
a an attempt at a calming email client
that chunks your email delivery into
into kind of depending on your
patterns but maybe seven emails or four
emails at a time and gives you awareness
of how many times you've been checking
your email how much how much processing
that you've been doing meaning like how
productive you've been doing relative to
your your normal days how much time
you've spent and so it's it's thinking
about email from the perspective of well
how can we have people every time they
check their email feel a sense of
accomplishment rather than um you know
overload right so and and I was talking
with this with different members of the
research team before class and there's
just just so many different ways to
approach well what could be calming for
a person when it comes to email you know
so I just I'm just showing some of it
and can talk about that later this was
one of our students that was working on
sleep and it was like you know not
necessarily what the quality of sleep
was but like but rather you know did you
hit your sleep goals this was a Stanford
wide game that he created and if your
sleep goals were only five hours per
night did you reach them
because a lot of times it's really about
feeling that you're doing okay and if
your sleep goals are five hours a night
but you feel good about that then that's
fine I may be after time you may want to
increase that but who are we to judge
we're just interested in the sense of
calm the state of calm this is one of
our students that was working on the
moment before going to sleep and the
anxiety and stress that she and her
participants were feeling and so she
said well if I'm gonna use the the the
technology before I go to sleep at least
I would prefer it to be reflective of
one of my values it's not a very high
quality screenshot but you you you
specify some of your values and then say
what happened today that to me that
fulfilled this value for me and and then
it would share that with another person
so creating some social connections so
that was her expression you can see that
you probably would never have guessed
that this is a calming technology right
and that's part of the class is that you
you go into your life and you go into
what you see
as where stressors are occurring and you
can create technology for that right
yeah bad communication in general it's
common that's in the sense what this is
right content looks interaction that's
just saying I'm thinking right and I'm
thinking of you at around I'm I'm
thinking I'm reflecting on my day and
I'm thinking of you as somebody who
would want to would care about that
because that's happening is like I was
reminded that this is one of my personal
values and this happened to me today
because of that and I want to share that
with one of a core member of people that
you have that's how she designed it yeah
yeah exactly which is what she was
really trying to do she was trying to
say you know if those moments before
sleep if they could change it from email
to like reflection of my day I mean
that's a that's a real shift right this
is another team at Stanford that created
this for Nokia they call it considerate
and the idea is that you have a you
start the day with a hundred and every
time you check your phone this number
goes down and then if you tilt it it
shows you like your email checking
patterns all right just to bring
awareness to it and their take is that
like you know it's really it's really if
we could increase the awareness of how
I'm using my phone how I'm relating to
my technology then this is a way of you
know bringing more awareness to my state
in general which would mitigate stress
and bring back that neutral state this
is a project where a researcher from
Sony was in the lab and in the class and
what he created was when he's texting
somebody instead of that person just
being like a you know just a name on the
screen he would press their face and
feel their heartbeat that person was
wearing heartrate monitor and would feel
and it would vibrate a little bit the
phone would vibrate and we tried it in
the class and it was just like wow this
is completely different this is totally
different you know it's a whole other
axis of interaction with with social
interaction people this was another
student who was working on eating
emotional overeating and she was
targeting women and she found that she
was talking with a lot of other people
and she found that you know when when
these women were feeling stressed they
would eat differently perhaps overeating
so she what she was creating was a
mindful eating thing where I won't go
into all the details but at some point
after the day it asks you these very
simple and fun questions so you reflect
back on how you're eating and so the
next time you're eating you know this
this thing is going to be coming up and
so it's like it brings a different level
of attention to your meal and what
you're eating in so this was a her and
you can totally see if you fast-forward
10 20 years from now and you look back
at like oh what do people start doing
then this was one of the the the you
know aims the research aims and this is
like the beginning of those experiments
with technological experiments in
bringing self awareness and self
regulation to the users this was a
project where it would automatically say
you know if you can choose a particular
person like your mother
and says well you haven't spoken to him
in 3 months would you like to do that
right so promoting social connection and
also what she found was that it was it
was like it wasn't necessarily talking
to your mom or Jane that was the most
calming thing necessarily but rather
mitigating the stress of like god I
haven't talked to my mom and three
months and like having the technology
kind of take care of that for you so you
may be yelling at your mama I don't know
but the point is is that that's what she
was working on that's what she was
targeting this was a task manager where
is a web-based task manager so he has
this to-do list there and the in the in
the right here so you can click on this
tab but he also keeps his finished list
right here very easily accessible which
he he found was that in and of itself
and having that number in
like that that was very calming for
people because these things weren't just
disappearing and it's the next batch of
stuff is just a never-ending to-do list
but rather okay there's a queue and they
go here making progress but also having
the ability for social interaction
within the the task list and he's even
experimenting around solving those tasks
for people but so and then also every
time you've completed a task this
background would change to this like
other really beautiful image so it's
kind of interesting this was a project
where your mom texts did you arrive and
you're like I don't feel like I've seen
you telling you just one button I'm okay
and it would send the mom your location
and would say she's okay and that's it
and it was like it was done and so you
would that let barrier to relieving the
anxiety of the mom was very low and so
that was her approach so I've shown you
a bunch of examples of how it ends up
looking for different students and what
we did is we kind of abstracted a simple
but useful theoretical model which is
you're a designer thinking about calming
technology understanding the nature of
stress and stressors for your particular
users is really crucial you can see when
when the students were naming the
stressors they're very precise and the
more precise the the better in a lot of
ways but then having some understanding
of what might be a calming mechanism
which might be an explicit attempt to
mitigate a stressor or it may be
actually introducing kamar like music or
breathing or something you know it has
nothing to do with existing stressors in
the system and and of course there's a
girl grounding and user centered design
and it's just really like these three
things that are on the table so this is
available online if your interest
because there's some interesting
references and explanations at the
bottom that are really like a cheat
sheet almost this is the yerkes-dodson
curve which is women working with a lot
and what it basically says is that you
know you don't want under stimulation
you don't want to be over stimulated you
want to be you know kind of this
optimal level and I think that's really
true and that makes a lot of sense but
what in my opinion is missing from this
is the the time dimension because what
we've seen in this kind of what what is
sustainable is not necessarily always
being in optimum stimulation because
it's there's there's definitely rhythms
to this arrest that needs to happen and
so on so this is kind of like thinking
that we've been doing around this and we
haven't really experimented much with it
but I wanted to explain that and looking
at all the student technologies that
were coming out we basically delineated
between there's these calm dedicated
approaches which were like very
explicitly this is going to calm you and
the other were calm augmented which were
existing technologies like word
processors this is one of the the most
recently created word processors on the
market and it looks like it's from 85
because it's it's really trying to
remove a lot of distractors so the goal
that the technology is not to be calm
the goal is to write the best you can
and so there including calming elements
in it some of these word processors have
like music that plays in certain ways I
mean it's it's interesting but just just
removing distractors bees a calming
technology right because you're
explicitly trying to create that state
for people another thing we did is we
tried to distill some design patterns
that we were noticing that students were
using and stuff I won't go into this but
there's a lot of potential here I think
and and we've been publishing a bit
right so one of the things that we
published last year was we looked at
Jacob Nielsen's heuristics for usability
which you probably familiar with and we
started thinking well what about
designers who want to ensure or evaluate
that their designs are not creating
unnecessary stress I mean and this is
like you know there's going to be stress
there using your system there's going to
be stress but how much awareness do you
have about how you might mitigate it as
much as possible so that's an example of
something that we've been doing New York
Times came to our lab which was really
fun this is this is a this is a photo of
our class and to the students
in the class I hold very dear to my
heart the idea that students really have
to be experientially kind of well-versed
in comm and so we do calming exercises
in the class and that can be very it can
be totally like you know meditation like
you might expect or just walking or just
standing behind someone and it's a
really fun exercise some time but or
breathing or progressive muscle
relaxation or so many different things
and then we designing from that space
with that that that subtle distinction
between the state and how a system may
influence a user I like this quote to
describe how such technologies may end
up being in in people's lives we're
going to move away from the era of I
have hundreds of apps would never think
of using them towards I have these cool
apps and they take care of me I mean you
can see like when when these came out
and everything yeah you get all the apps
and it's just kind of like okay I have a
billion apps you know and it's like it's
not it's not it's getting old in a way
right but there's still the potential of
how those apps interact with us again
mostly for myself but feel free to use
this time for yourself so let me let me
explain stress in this this is like the
best diagram that I've ever seen about
stress so here's how it goes so you have
a certain amount a certain
characteristic of individual differences
right and the the brain perceives stress
differently from people didn't perceive
it differently and according to
different environmental stressors life
events trauma from the past and so on
and there's these behavioral responses
smoking drinking email checking you know
these all go in the same category if you
thought that you were above that and
then there's these physiologic responses
and what happens is is that
based upon your physiologic responses
you end up with a certain amount of a
low static load in the body so it's kind
of like you're boiling some milk and if
you turn everything really high and it
might just burn over but if you keep it
at a low simmer appropriately you can
heat it well and so on right so it's
kind of like you have to below it it's
kind of like how much this thing is that
this this milk this is the metaphor we
use in the class but how much this milk
is gonna boil over or burn and so on now
one of the things that's interesting is
that in the physiologic responses the
pupils dilate your muscles may clench
the blood flow changes in the body your
heart rate changes and your breathing
changes and of all those indicators in
there are more the one that you have
conscious control of is the breathing
which is why a lot of research goes into
breathing because you can sense it
yourself you don't know when your pupils
are dilating or even when your heart
rate increases unless it's really
pounding but you can see your breath
quite easily that's really the only
reason I mean I shouldn't say the only
reason
so in effect stress affects your breath
rate and it's been shown during exams
and homework computer data entry and the
threat of electric shock so what's
interesting about this is that you know
the body is reacting
similarly in these different situations
I have to take an exam I might be
electrically shocked the body is very
similar so in fact what you're doing to
your body if you're not regulating
self-regulating is you're putting your
body under under stress continuously
like it may be being attacked or injured
okay so this is the comic or this is an
art piece that I think reflects why the
breath is important to people different
kinds of researchers and psychiatrists
and contemplative practitioners and so
on it's really just being aware of where
that where your energy is and what your
state is so what we started doing now
now talking about
what we did one of the things we built
is we built this very rudimentary
respiration sensor that she would wear
around your abdomen and you know
originally it was wired and then it was
wireless and then it was extreme
interior iPhone in real time so we're
like wow you know let's try to - just to
see if we can help people with breath
awareness breath of regulation those
people who wanted to of course so we we
validated our sensor against other other
sensors on the market that weren't ours
and one of the first things we did is we
try to say well what if we could help
people breathe differently when they're
at the computer it's a little screen
apnea thing so that's where we started
and and we created this really funny but
sorry this funny attempt at that I hope
it plays okay so here you are working in
Excel and then this thing that the
computer determines oh there you're
stressed and it would just send this bar
up and now you can continue working so
part of our goal was to make it
peripheral and it was like this is your
resting rate this is your individual
resting right that's what it did it was
okay this is just a really a reminder
and a little bit of a guide so you can
ignore it
you can also in train to it up to you
that was one of our design glavine from
a HCI perspective it's like you know we
didn't want to stop the screen and be
like hey you're stressed breathe or go
take a break or do these kind of things
it was like really important to us to
help people maintain the productivity
and know and feel that they can maintain
productivity while self-regulating so we
did an interesting study showing that
here's a user's breath rate while
they're at the computer and here's that
user when the the thing was showing up
the peep the bar and you can see their
breath rates going down right but what
happens right after the breath the bar
goes away is their breath rate goes like
back up it's like oh it's you know out
of sight out of mind kind of thing right
so then we were like okay so let's see
if we can sustain
the change using social feedback you
know here are these other people and so
we did this fun study which worked like
this you had two conditions in one
condition we told that the users hey
these people are when they're breathing
calmly right now and there's this big
game at Stanford and the more calm you
breathe the more points we get and
there's this whole thing and like
they're in other room in another room
like breathing calmly at this time and
the other condition it was like okay
this was from yesterday but they were
breathing calmly at those times and if
you breathe calmly you'll show up on
other people's bars like that right and
what we found is just the belief of that
this was happening in real time
changed the the the breathing pattern so
here's someone's breathing rate here is
that during the synchronous condition
and here's that they're in asynchronous
condition so what we were interested in
is seeing you know first of all we saw a
difference but also what was the
difference was it a magnify effect or a
persistent meaning was it like a
persistent change like their breath rate
would come down more in the synchronous
condition or it would just come down
more drastically and we found that it
was the latter it was like these really
precipitous Falls in breath rate so it
was like oh it's kind of social pressure
which may in fact be stressful but
that's what we that's what we noticed so
we took those and we started to kind of
experiment with a little bit of a
peripheral more peripheral approach that
wasn't cueing the user like that so we
started to integrate the biofeedback
into the operating system with points
and and and so on
we we showed the user here's here's what
the screen looked like when you were
breathing most quickly and most slowly
so you can kind of say oh that's those
are the activities that were causing me
the most stress perhaps when you hit
milestones and your breathing rates over
the course of a day we would show these
calming images like hey you reached 100
points that we created this thing called
points you know just to experiment with
this idea because it was just really
there was no work on it and then we
would show these operant conditioning
things like hey you just had like in
case you didn't know you were just
breathing really calmly for the past
six minutes so whatever you were doing
let me take note of that or the opposite
hey you know you're you seem to be
stressing right now and often when
people see this they're like well that
would stress me out and maybe it would
but you have to remember that our
participants we're people that were
already saying we want to have feedback
around this topic because we they were
interested in in breath regulation we
also experimented with social feedback
and so on so the crux of this idea lies
in that thing we call the breath tray
which was this this is this this piece
of peripheral feedback about your state
at the moment and this was the the
poster that we published about it
influencing self regulation without
cognitive deficit and the idea was we
wanted to see if people could
self-regulate effectively without
interrupting their task too much because
people were coming to us saying well I
don't want this feedback because I need
to get my work done I can't just like be
thinking about my breath all the time so
we had these different tasks where very
cognitively intense tasks one was a
single task one was a multi task and and
saw and to look at the differences and
what we found was that just very quickly
basically during multitasking you're not
able to self-regulate use the feedback
to come back to your resting breath rate
during the serial sevens test which was
a mono task
you know like I'm working on this like
programming or something there was
enough attentional resources to devote
to that self-regulated process which was
you know and maybe another reason why
multitasking can be stressful
you really can't devote the attention to
where you're at so we took those
takeaways and again we started to we
have we have we had this this very
rudimentary sensor and we started
streaming that data to the iPhone and
basically did what we did on the desktop
except getting it on the phone and one
of the first things we found was that as
soon as it's on the phone it was a it
was a very different way of giving
feedback to people because it's a very
intimate it's like part of your body in
a way
and so you had feedback around about
your state in something this close to
you it wasn't on the screen any longer
this screen it was on this screen so you
know one of the things that we had to do
was was think about how we give feedback
to people and one of them was having
real-time feedback about your state was
less valuable than feedback about the
recent past so we introduced this kind
of in the past ten minutes you're in the
green or you know what you're in the
yellow or possibly in the red and and
that was more useful to like this is
what number you are right now stuff like
that so this is just the very beginning
of this kind of work so you see some of
the similar push reminders that I showed
you in the desktop also breathing
exercises and points but also being able
to see you know your history and and
then what we wanted to do is is quickly
yeah so basically be able to help people
determine what activities and what
environments were most stressful to them
so we would ask them at at appropriate
times capture the effectivity that
you're engaged in or you're about to
about to start driving or flying or
taking the test or at the computer and
then it would later reflect that
information to you so this is uh one of
our participants who self labeled her
data and showed that just for her own
her own edification that you know her
breath right while she was meditating
was very different from when she was
reading or just surfing the web an
activity that she thought was very you
know just sitting there surfing the web
but her breath rate showed differently
so we gave this system to five different
users over the course of several days we
found different things one was that one
user had way more compr than other users
and they had a very different
distribution they had a bimodal
distribution of their breathing rates
over the course of a week and we went
back and we found out that this user was
in fact a meditator so they were
somebody that was maintaining awareness
of their breathing and that we didn't
know
that ahead of time and it was kind of
like wow that's fascinating but you're
able to really still see this and by the
way I mean there isn't an ambulatory
respiration sensor available so this is
the first bell curve of respiration
rates ambulatory you know meaning you
know as wearable that we've seen and
I've tried to find and it can't really
so it's just the beginning of what's
possible with looking at respiratory
patterns and and and and shifting those
to be yeah taxi driver would have much
more stressful lifestyle than this a
librarian who's sorting books yeah I
mean it's it's really centered around
their own resting rate so these were
these were participants that were
interested in in developing their breath
awareness and regulation they were
already interested in reducing their
stress it wasn't a comparison between
individuals so much like see like yeah
we are but we didn't for this but we are
yeah I mean okay so we didn't attempt to
answer your question we didn't attempt
to control for but in practice these
were all information workers but it
wasn't the goal of doing that yeah
looking at that there was Delta's from
resting are they pretty much the same
sugar Delta's across people no they're
very different I mean so you can see you
can see the distribution of people's
breathing rates is quite different right
you have a classic bell curve you have
this this person over here that doesn't
very much and then you have this guy who
you know had a whole different thing
going on I had this whole other mode of
respiration really this is a
visualization of how push notifications
from the system were influencing the
breathing patterns of the users and you
can see the red are like hey you're
stressed you know and seeing what
happens after that's this we didn't
anyway that's what that is and I'm much
time gonna quickly go through this but I
wanted to show you this is our one of
the horrible things about the sensor is
you have to wear it like a belt it's
like this it's not it's comfortable but
it's annoying so we've been working on
this new sensor which uses something
called the Hall effect which is
basically a measure of the magnetic
field and so I have it with me you guys
come up and try it afterwards but it's
basically you you kind of put it on your
pants or your bra or something and and
as you're breathing and as you're your
abdomen changes its print it's putting a
little bit of pressure on this and we're
able to pick up the breathing patterns
really well and including other things
like sighing and laughing and speech we
think that we can do like crying and
other things so this is because because
we want to like want to do a wider scale
study and we've new giving this to
people was going to be too annoying and
it had too many problems with it so
that's where we're going now we've been
experimenting with that and you know
being able to see a lot of different
being able to capture a lot of different
things like here's a here's a cough you
know here's what it looks like and so on
so we're just in the midst of like of
being would accurately interpret the
data so right now we're doing this study
with Elissa EPEL at UCSF who's at the
aim lab who's really the telomere lab
where they're doing we're doing a study
with two different rupes of mothers one
who one group has children who are
artistic and one group has children who
are not so one group is the high stress
group and we're seeing if with the
breath regulation and breath awareness
we're able to maintain their telomere
length really and so it's very exciting
and the other approach the other
research vane is the integration of this
data into our productivity tools so of
course there's like the breath work
that's happening but also how do you
change the their productivity
environment that we're in the
interactions with our our email or
texting or phone all these going to kind
of things so that's
that's how what we're kind of starting
to think about now and lastly this is
work I'm doing now with Jacob a visiting
professor from Denmark is thinking about
how how our interaction designs and not
only do influence our habits of mind but
how we can explicitly try to influence
the habit of mind in a particular way
right so do we have a point of view on
how what are a great habits of mind
perhaps and the mindfulness community
this is what they do so kind of
borrowing from them and the stress
research to think about you know having
more clarity around how our technologies
are changing our habits of mind not just
our habits of interaction but actually
our habits of mind so like how many
times you're checking the phone and
reacting to incoming data and stuff like
that so the last slide is thank you
thanks for your attention and I'm always
open to research collaborators there's a
lot of people that come from different
fields that are interested I mean
there's like medical students come and
we chats and electrical engineers they
wanna they want to chat so really just
if you're interested in talking I'm
always open and thanks for your
attention
in mine yeah had a question so it seems
like a lot of activity seemed to be
stressful and I can understand what
exams stressful and it can understand
possibly why email the stressed word
simply because there's an expectation of
successful and but I don't see by data
entry are surfing the web can be
stressful so I'm wondering what are the
principal components of activities that
make in stressful
why is surfing the web stressful but
reading a book not yeah so I have my
theory on that and it is that the way
that window management is designed just
ground up and the way screens are
designed and it it has no rhythm there's
no element of rhythm to it there's no
it's not designed to for humans it's
designed for machines it's like just you
know what I mean it looks like it's a
it's a machine made made for machines
and so I think that there's no there's
no kind of in-between moments there's no
like micro pauses or down times and
things kind of just appear I mean so you
know Apple has the little thing where it
you know the the windows come from a
place and so on and in an attempt to
make it a little more naturalistic I
think and that I honestly think that
those things help but I think there's
work to be done to like really like
starting from scratch based on like what
what are the the best ways to interact
with with a human that's working in an
effort to maintain that efficiency of
interaction because that's what's really
great is very efficient but without
without kind of requiring because if you
watch somebody at a computer it's like
their eyes actually are opened wide you
know which is the really great indicator
they're stressed or they're under some
amount of mild stress right I mean it's
not like they're freaking out but you
know it's there so you can you can also
watch yourself to is like well what was
happening there but watching other
people is far more illustrative I'm
curious to see how can the compares
let's see
yeah I mean just the whole mono tasking
of it I think it that in itself is a big
differentiator yeah
Michael spending time here I really
became part of this culture of smiling
greater stress and spending six years on
the East Coast Iowa scene is really
geared because in the exacting the exact
same stimulus would happen that you
actually externalise it say I'm so
stressed out I am so many things due
soon and I think part of it was a bit of
a culture of commiseration together and
this was how they actually got through
it and I'm wondering if there might be a
bit of an implicit decision in some of
these designs that you're exploring
about whether you should be helping
people actually sort of smile through or
external eyes to their friends and I
wonder if you thought about that in your
designs or what if that's even something
that should be considered I heard you I
don't know what it doesn't matter so
it's a really subtle and interesting
point I I don't okay good so I don't
think that that the designs that we do
doing have been the smile through
everything by any stretch I mean I think
that but they're also not encouraging
people to share this dress well maybe
not the ones I showed you I mean it
really depends on how people are how
people are approaching how the designers
approaching it so we've seen all types
but I think that
we've been what we did is we we went and
looked at the psychology of stress like
what is considered stressful and it's
really unpredictability and you can't
predict something or you feel a lack of
control or a social evaluative threat to
your person or your property these are
these are like things that are actually
like you can pretty much say these are
the probability that it's high they're
gonna feel some stress and we try to
mitigate those things and the emergence
of those feelings in the interface
that's been our approach there's been
some some some work where it's like
there's the others there's one app
called like making me smile where the
student said you know what puppies
pictures of puppies make me smile I'm
gonna make an app that has pictures of
puppies and it's just designed in a
really engaging way but in the end its
puppies and I think that you know I I
think that you could look at that and
say that's a smile through it for us not
actually kind of releasing it or not
dealing with it but it also could be
looked at depending on the user I was
like a reminder right but most recently
I totally acknowledge that the release
the appropriate release is really
important and in fact I heard a theory
of what stress is that stress is when
the release doesn't happen it's not what
caused it it's actually just the
inappropriate release or adaptation to
the stressor which is fascinating to me
because then it means like if you you
know if you're feeling stressed like
release it and you won't be stressed
anymore which is like you know maybe
it's true sometimes and you're not other
times and I think there's something
there
so especially and you know in the west
coast where we have the you know the
stand for the whole thing it's not
necessarily true that if you're smiling
through it you're not stressed you know
and
you know so it's a really interesting
discussion yeah thank you James that
reading laughter and possibly crying so
you've begun to explore how to into
feedback structure as well we have it
because it's just been a very recent
that the sensor has been able to do that
but we had like you know we had cool
ideas you know it's just really the
beginning of that because on the way I
see like the sensor sensors sensors that
we have now like that are kind of out
there and people are using like the
fitbit's of the world like their
accelerometers that's what they are I
mean and there's other things they do
loosely even basis just kind of like
they do heartrate like only when you're
not moving and stuff but what I think
we're interested in is like like
meaningful easy to interpret a human
meaningful data like accelerometer is
like machine interesting and perhaps you
could interpret that in a way that's
like kind of interesting but it's very
indirect to your actual life and how you
experience your life and so you know
breathing laughing talking sighing I
mean like they're like it's very like
we'll see what happens a little bit
we're gonna see how we can because the
population is so used to heart rate you
know as being really important it is but
how meaningful is it to to us like
without being interpreted by the machine
so we're just starting that so the long
answer to interesting question so it's
two o'clock
thank you so much
you